[Music]
yeah they smell that that's death
what the hell is this place this is
what's left of Kong's pants I've taken
enough photos of mass graves to
recognize one crash sites just on the
other side of its valley will cross
through and make it to the highest point
with uh-huh this place is a real no no
sir we need to be going to the north
side right now and you're welcome to do
that my man by yourself not leaving Jack
out there now who's with me
we can make it mighty right we can make
it now stay sharp keep an eye out I've
only been here 28 years where do I know
respond Fox free
[Music]
then a monkey
well if you look at that it bleeds we
did that hookup with Chapman there's
enough munitions on there down sea
stallion to finish the job
magnificent no why I carry lists instead
of an m16 took it off a farmer fighting
for the NVA he surrendered right after
we leveled his village he was fifty
years old said he'd never even seen a
gun till we showed up sometimes
an enemy doesn't exist do you're looking
for him what happens when they show up
on your doorstep I'll still have his gun
that's the luck with that soldier
you are going to tell me everything I
don't know I'm going to blow your head
off
monsters exist yesterday I was a
crackpot but today you dropped those
charges to flush something out who are
you
ancient species on this earth long
before mankind and if we keep our heads
buried in the sand they will take it
back my agency is known as monarch we
specialized in the hunt for massive
unidentified terrestrial organisms you
knew that thing was out here I'm sorry
for your men colonel
I truly am get us home with proof so we
can send the cavalry
[Music]
you
[Music]
an uncharted island let me list all the
ways you're gonna die need
disease-carrying flies Tammy haven't
started on the things that want to beat
your life will double their plus a bonus
if we make it back in this studio
that's calm is God on the island The
Devil's live Lois I calm skull crawlers
why cuz it sounds neat
okay look I just made that name up I'm
trying to scare you
I'm fine calling them that are you go
away yeah
these are photos of an island in the
South Pacific the place where myth and
science me we use explosives to shake
the earth helping us to map the surface
of the island you're dropping bombs
scientific instruments
I'm walking
[Music]
magnificent
you knew that thing was out here I'm
sorry for your man girl but if you want
to make this sacrifice worthwhile get us
home with proof monsters exist
your friend there can put that down what
the hell is this place
that's calm he's King around here comas
pretty good King keeps to himself mostly
well you don't go into someone's house
and start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight we call his God on the
island but the devil's live below us and
what if a calls
I call them skull crores why never said
that name out loud before it sounds
stupid now that I say just you call them
whatever you want
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here
it's a survey job just chopper them in
and out be a joyride
[Music]
you are going to tell me everything I
don't know
I'm gonna blow your head off
this planet doesn't belong to us
each species on this earth long before
mankind I spent 30 years trying to prove
the truth monsters exist
you don't go into someone's house unless
you're making a fight
what you're looking at from my god
it's kick
this is a satellite photo of an
uncharted island in the South Pacific
a place where myth and science meet
Kong has been rican sieved as a myth
come to life you came here looking for a
dragon who all was am i tracking
the island isn't just a place that looks
specifically like one thing as you
continue to travel through it you see
the variations it's never been touched
you don't know what to expect like any
natural jungle there are predators
you don't go into someone's house and
start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight
Kong is killing his men so it becomes
his mission
I became they have he was my white whale
we're very happy to say that we have the
biggest Kong of them all he is truly
monstrous in size and scale and scope
when people step foot on this island
the first visceral response is to look
at that thing and say that's a god
that's the big one
this film will be an immersive spectacle
calling Skull Island has things you
haven't seen before it takes you to a
different world where things are
beautiful and terrifying all at the same
time
it's huge and we're talking about one of
the greatest myths of all time
this is a satellite photo of an
uncharted island in the South Pacific
a place where myth and science mean
has been rican sieved as a myth come to
life
this film will be an immersive spectacle
he got Kong it's a hundred feet tall it
really has to be seen in IMAX the whole
movie just gets taken to the next level
wash in IMAX
you really just lose yourself what the
hell is this place
it tells this incredible story of man
versus nature you came here looking for
a track at who or what am i tracking
I've been looking for this island for
years get us home
with proof monsters exist the island
isn't just a place that looks
specifically like one thing as you
continue to travel through it you see
the variations it's never been touched
you don't know what to expect like any
natural jungle there are predators
go into someone's house and start
dropping bombs unless you're picking a
fight
Kong is killing his men so it becomes
his mission it's time to show that man
is king he's not an animal he's not a
beast he's a being and it's just
something that we don't understand yet
he is truly monstrous in size and scale
and scope when people step foot on this
island
their first visceral response just look
at that thing and say that's a god
that's the big one
I hope the film inspires Wanda and/or
Kong Skull Island takes you to a
different world where things are
beautiful and terrifying all at the same
time it's IMAX and it's 3d it's huge and
we're talking about one of the greatest
myths of all time
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here you see the
coming
you